mohamed decidió registrar el número de
hojas de un árbol que está en su patio
trasero durante el primer año obtuvo 500
hojas y cada año a partir de entonces el
número era 40% mayor que el año anterior
se ha n un entero positivo tal que f de
n denota el número de hojas del árbol de
mohamed en el enésimo año a partir de
que comenzó a contarlas entonces la
expresión fn define una sucesión de
tipos de sucesión es ft n y estaría muy
bien que tú pensarás en tu cabeza este
problema pero es muy sencillo si el
árbol está creciendo en un 40% esto es
lo mismo que multiplicar por 1.4 y cada
término sucesivo se estará multiplicando
o dividiendo por el mismo número en este
caso 1.4 y justo esa es la sucesión
geométrica entonces aquí le pondríamos
geométrico pero qué te parece si lo
hacemos un poco más visible para que
veas con mayor claridad
este problema así que para eso voy a
hacer por aquí una pequeña tabla y voy a
hacer por aquí una pequeña tabla de este
lado voy a tener a n y aquí voy a tener
a efe de n ok que pasa cuando n vale 1
bueno cuando n vale 1 estamos hablando
del primer año y dice que durante el
primer año obtuvo 500 hojas ese es el
dato que me dan
así que fd n es 500 después cuando n
vale 2 en el segundo año bueno dice cada
año a partir de entonces el número era
40% mayor que el año anterior así que
habrá que multiplicar a esto por 1.4 por
1.4 y que voy a obtener 500 por 1.4 es
lo mismo que sumarle 200 a 500 por lo
tanto me va a quedar 700 700 y en el
tercer año
bueno pues otra vez habrá que aumentar
el 40 por ciento lo que quiere decir que
a 700 lo voy a multiplicar por 1
punto 4 y bueno 700 por 1.4 es lo mismo
que aumentarle 280 700 es decir me va a
quedar 980 así que observa que está en
definitiva no es una sucesión aritmética
en una sucesión aritmética sumamos o
restamos siempre la misma cantidad pero
aquí no pasamos de 500 a 700 lo cual es
crecer en 200 y de 700 a 900 80 lo cual
es crecer en 280 por lo tanto no es una
sucesión aritmética en este caso estamos
multiplicando por la misma cantidad
siempre por 1.4 por lo que claramente es
una sucesión geométrica y entonces esta
sería la primera parte de nuestro
problema ahora déjame bajar un poco la
pantalla y sigamos leyendo dice
dependiendo de tu respuesta la
definición recursiva de la sucesión
puede tener una de las dos formas
siguientes aritmética o geométrica pero
ya sabemos que aritmética no es por lo
tanto déjame quitarlo por aquí y vamos a
aplicarnos en la geométrica
ahora esta es la definición recursiva de
esta sucesión geométrica nos dicen
cuáles son los valores de los parámetros
a ive para esta sucesión y bueno en este
caso deja de subir un poco la pantalla
cuando me fijo en a date cuenta que
tenemos el caso base
fd n es igual a si n es igual a 1 pero
sabemos que cuando n vale 1 el valor de
fd n es 500 por lo tanto en este caso
va a valer 500 déjame ponerlo así en
lugar de voy a poner 500 que es nuestro
caso base cuando n vale 1 y aquí lo voy
a escribir también 500 muy bien y veamos
qué pasa si tenemos un año que no es el
primer año bueno pues es lo que nos dice
la otra parte de la función tenemos si
en es más grande que uno si no estamos
en el primer año entonces tomamos el año
anterior y lo multiplicamos por b
entonces quién sería b bueno pues es
justo lo que sabemos crecemos en un 40
por ciento y si crecemos en un 40 por
ciento entonces tomamos el año anterior
y lo multiplicamos por 1.4 estás de
acuerdo por lo tanto ve vale 1.4 es
justo lo que nos dicen aquí si no
tenemos el caso base entonces tomamos el
año anterior y lo multiplicamos por 1.4
por lo tanto ve vale 1.4 y así ya
tenemos la solución de este problema así
que qué te parece si hacemos uno más y
para eso
déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla porque
ahora quiero trabajar con este problema
dice
iuc organizó una fiesta compró 50
recuerdos para regalar y les dio tres
recuerdos a cada uno de sus invitados
conforme llegaban a la fiesta sea n un
entero positivo tal que gtn de note el
número de recuerdos que si yo tenía
antes antes de que el enésimo
invitado llegará ok antes
antes de leer estas preguntas déjame
hacer por aquí una tabla para ver si
estoy entendiendo el problema déjame
hacer por aquí una tabla y por acá
también para ver qué nos dice este
problema aquí voy a tener a n y aquí
así que veamos qué pasa cuando n vale 1
y cuando n vale 1 vamos a leer con calma
esta oración de aquí sea n un entero
positivo tal que gtn denota el número de
recuerdos el número de recuerdos que se
unión tenía antes de que el enésimo
invitado llegara es decir que antes de
que el primer invitado llegar a cuantos
recuerdos tenía su jung bueno pues
empezó con 50 estás de acuerdo así que
no le ha dado ningún recuerdo a ningún
invitado porque está antes de que
llegara el primero así que empezamos con
50 muy bien y qué pasa cuando tengo n
igual a 2
bueno pues antes de que llegue el
segundo invitado pues habrá llegado el
primer invitado y por lo tanto ya habrá
entregado tres recuerdos al primer
invitado entonces cuando n vale 2 tengo
47 47 recuerdos restantes y qué pasa
cuando n vale 3 bueno antes de que
llegue el tercer invitado ya habrá
llegado el segundo y el primero y a cada
de ellos le habrá dado tres recuerdos
por lo tanto tres del primero y tres el
segundo en ese momento ya le quedan 44
44 recuerdos y creo que ya empieza a ver
el patrón en esta tabla cuando n aumenta
en 1 date cuenta que cdn lo que pasa es
que disminuye en 3 y cuando aumente otra
vez el 1 disminuye otra vez en 3 y por
lo tanto como en cada paso vamos a
disminuir la misma cantidad entonces
estamos hablando de una sucesión
aritmética donde siempre disminuimos la
misma cantidad y después dice escribe
una fórmula explícita para la asociación
así que vamos a ver si la encontramos
gdn es igual y empezamos con 50
recuerdos así que lo voy a poner aquí 50
recuerdos ya esto se encuentra recuerdos
lo que vamos a hacer es quitarle tres
veces tres veces cuánto
ok bien tenemos en esta tabla cuando n
valía 1 quitamos a 0 veces 3 recuerdos
por lo tanto nos quedamos en 50 cuando n
baleados quitamos una vez 3 recuerdos
para llegar al 47 cuando en el día 3
quitamos una dos veces tres para llegar
al 44 así que cuando tengamos el enésimo
término
bueno pues habíamos quitado n 1 veces
así que aquí tendría n menos 1 ojo date
cuenta de lo siguiente cuando n vale 3
ya quitamos una dos veces 3 de 50 para
llegar a este número 44 cuando n vale 2
lo que quitamos fue una vez una vez 3 y
cuando en la valía 1 quitamos 0 veces 3
por eso este funciona bastante bien aquí
poner n 1 y ver que todo concuerde si
por ejemplo en el vale uno me quedaría
50 menos 3 que multiplica a 1 - 1 es
cero
entonces me quedaría con
cuenta así que ya está está va a ser
nuestra expresión nuestra fórmula
explícita para esta asociación así que
vamos a escribirle aquí 50 menos 3 por n
menos 1 y bueno mi consejo o lo que yo
te recomiendo es que siempre trabajes
con la tabla sea cual sea el problema
trabajes con la tabla para ver si aquí
nos va a quedar en 1 o n o ver bien qué
es lo que está pasando para que así
tengas todas tus respuestas correctas